foreign
let's go out to Amanda in Kansas City
what's up Amanda
hello
how are you I I literally couldn't be
better how are you
excellent what's up um so my question
today
um
so we're in babysit
um I started to listen to mtas last fall
and
um I'm kind of backtracking so we've
been kind of doing like all the steps at
once and at this point I have one big
expense that needs to be paid off it's
my vehicle
and I'm having a hard time justifying
doing it well you're you're trying to do
all the steps at once
I'm trying to be babysit too what
happens what do they call it when you
hit all of the steps I feel like going
up the stairs and you hit them all at
once what does that mean you've done
you face plane did you ate it don't do
don't do them all at once that's falling
down all right um George save this
seriously why pay off the car
yeah well what's your car payment
um well it's like 560 a month but I've
been paying more on it
um
why would you not pay it off so the
question is if I was able to hand you
560 a month for the rest of your life
wouldn't you rather take that than pay
it to A lender with interest
um but if I could use it for other
things while I'm
using that money that logic makes no
sense right now you're in the whole 560.
I'm up 560. who has more options me or
you
so okay so here's here's my thoughts on
this so it's a pretty low interest rate
which I know that's like that doesn't
it's not supposed to matter nobody cares
versus more stupid okay
keep telling us about Amanda's plan keep
going if I if I pay it off then I'm
going to feel like I'm constantly car
shopping I'm like always looking at cars
this feels like you have a nice car what
car is this
um it's a it's a Telluride oh that's a
sick whip what are those things 60 Grand
um and I I got a better deal on it than
that what do you make a year
uh between my husband and I were at 2 30
a year you're crushing it why do you
need a car payment
here I I I I heard what she was saying
you want to keep a fight you're charging
yourself 560 dollars because you can't
close an internet browser
okay you have to you have to deal with
the fact that you think that your joy
and happiness are somewhere other than
where you are sitting
you're just chasing happiness you're
chasing it it's elusive
you will never catch this
is I feel like so we've got funds like
I've got funds and rental rental account
and stuff like that that I don't really
want to touch but I have a
emergency fund you know like our
you know three to six months I have that
I could deplete that and pay this off
that's exactly what you should do and
there's a 99.9 chance you will not do it
we can't help people who don't want the
help and it sounds like Amanda's plan is
better than a proven plan that's helped
millions of people become wealthy you
like you like spending five to six
hundred bucks a month to have your
account numbers look nice over here and
your internet browser down over here you
got to grow up and be an adult
you got to grow up being you'll make too
much money to be this broke pay off your
stupid car for crying out loud and then
get on with your life and make you guys
tell your money where to go instead of
till you ride Amanda
geez this is the Ramsay show